one of the worst kept secrets in all of
television history is the fact that
Adult Swim's Rick and Morty is filled to
the brim with Easter eggs
tongue-in-cheek references and obvious
Omar jizz to all things pop culture
well co-creators dan harmon and justin
roiland have imbued the sci-fi adventure
comedy series with a ton of clear film
and television mentions they've also
incorporated at least a double that
amount under the radar here are some
references in Rick and Morty that you
may have missed community for fans have
been around the television watching
block a few times before it's hardly a
shock to learn that series co-creator
Dan Harmon was subrange behind NBC's
community
unfortunately community out of troubled
six-year run temporarily losing Harmon
as a showrunner and switching networks
before it was finally canceled and Rick
and Morty Harmon pokes some serious fun
at the downfall of community getting the
series soft spots in season two's
auto-erotic assimilation Rick and is
on-again off-again collective hivemind
lover unity are watching television with
the events playing outs on screen
controlled by unity itself no make them
all make fun of the blonde one now make
them all do it on the table can't
believe you created a whole show for me
no cancel it okay now put it back on and
if there was any doubts the whole crew
appears on screen a moment later weekend
at Bernie's the 1989 black comedy
weekend at Bernie's follows a pair of
low-level suits working at a New York
insurance company who end up spending
their labor day weekend hauling around
their dead boss Bernie and trying to
convince everyone he's still alive
classic right
among the bits in season 1 60 minutes
there's a spoof trailer for a movie that
centers around the dead elderly woman
being puppeted by her cats what are the
kitties to do but buckle together and
work as a team last will and testament
weakened a dead cat lady's house - hail
to the king the season 1 episode is
something record this way comes isn't
shy about its inspiration it's a sci-fi
mashup of Ray Bradbury's 1962 dark
fantasy novel Something Wicked This Way
Comes in which a mysterious man gives
the locals their greatest desires it's
not exactly subtle detection catalogues
all your Twilight Zone Ray Bradbury
Friday the 13th the series voodoo crap
magic it's also an obvious riff on
Stephen King's classic horror book
needful things where an elderly man runs
a very weird dangerous shop but the
vintage horror references don't end
there I'm here to pick up my own get cat
and child
well the quip may just seem like typical
Rick and Morty irreverence it's actually
a subtle reference to Stephen King's
1983 horror novel Pet Sematary which
follows the Creed family they're plagued
by back-to-back tragedies the accidental
deaths of their cat and their
two-year-old son both of whom
disturbingly come back to life as
demonic weirdos determined to kill and
the fourth-dimensional testicle monsters
from a wrinkle in time they're a
spitting image of the terrifying
time-bending creatures seen in the 1995
miniseries Elango leas based on a story
by stephen king saud us raising
gazorpazorp will likely go down in rick
and morty history as one of the
strangest episodes the series has ever
put forth but with all its uniqueness
the word references hidden throughout
like the Footloose tribute that sees
Morty jr. busting and angsty move in an
abandoned warehouse and who could miss
the raising Arizona not in the title but
it goes deeper than that
when reckons summer pay a visit to cos
or paws or in the Andromeda system they
see a giant floating head fly in to drop
down artificially crafted women used for
procreation the head is almost identical
to the one seen in the 1974 sci-fi cult
film Asada's a flick co-creator harmon
told his harmontown podcast listeners to
watch back in april 2013
Animal Farm George Orwell's Animal Farm
gets a few carefully crafted references
throughout the lawnmower dog episode of
Rick and Morty and in case you're
counting that title is another Stephen
King reference when the family's pet pup
snuffles gained sentience and decides to
take down all of humanity he uses his
powers to construct a full bodysuit and
express just how angry he is about the
way dogs have grown from wild beasts to
humans playthings it's a progression of
events that loosely mimics what's seen
in Orwell's allegorical novella but
that's just surface level stuff there's
also this scene where snuffles decides
to change his name dad he wants to be
cops well I'm not calling him that
that's ridiculous
if you know your literature snowball is
the name of one of the main characters
in Animal Farm Buck Rogers in the 25th
century there are about a thousand
reasons why the noble bird person is
such a cherish to Rick and Morty
character but even his character is
borrowed wholesale from 1980s sci-fi the
TV series Buck Rogers in the 25th
century had no shortage of interesting
characters but it was the alien named
hawk who really stood out
porca played by Tom Christopher was a
half man half bird warrior who
represented the last of a dying breed of
bird people a background bird person
himself possesses or convert person are
similar in appearance as well one
thing's for certain we wouldn't put it
past a Rick and Morty to weave a web as
weird as one that links Buck Rogers to
their own multi-dimensional chaos aliens
are plenty Rick and Morty has been
riding the reference train from the
get-go pause the pilot for just a moment
get an up-close and personal look at the
visually complex space poor sequence and
your notice that a number of the
silhouettes shown are actually classic
pop culture figures near the center of
the frame are three creatures that look
exactly like the wisecracking robots Tom
servo crow T robot and a gypsy from the
sci-fi comedy series Mystery Science
Theater 3000 nearby there's a shadow
that resembles a terrifying xenomorph or
from the alien film franchise way over
to the left-hand side of the screen
there's a carbon copy of the blippi
alien figure from the 1978 arcade game
space invaders and of course a
gratuitous Ferengi from Star Trek
gravity falls if you didn't have your
peepers peeled you may have missed a few
quick nods to Disney's gravity falls
created by Justin roiland friend alex
hirsch look closely during the ceiling
closure it counters of the rekt kind and
you'll see a pen no pad and a mug emerge
from a portal the exact same item stand
drops through a portal in gravity falls
Society of the blind eye episode and
during big trouble at little Sanchez you
can spot an image of gravity falls main
antagonist bill cipher on an alien
computer screen even deeper than that in
the season 3 premiere the Rick shank
redemption a morty is seen holding what
appears to be journal 3 from gravity
falls as he walks through the Citadel of
Rick's and have so many off-kilter
versions of the duo insights you may not
have spotted a set of Morty twins in the
background one is wearing dippers
Pinetree hat and the other has on
Mabel's headbands and supports her
signature hairstyle that's the way
[Applause]
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]